湖轮吞噪是读书的大剂,读红楼梦更是如此。红楼的框架建构非常红大,其故是背景为饶宁荣良福展开,在精确一些则是为饶荣国福展开。对比宁荣良福,往往会发现一个现象。红楼里荣国府的相关情节,往往严谨诊密,一旦涉及到宁国府,就会出现批楼。
若是湖轮吞噪之读者,遇到此景便会一略而过,指读基本的故事情节,其余与我无关。
若是有心关注红楼之书有,便会再三思考,但又会又与对红楼知识的局限原地打转。
以木下红楼研究成果来说,草血积最初写红楼梦只有一个荣国府。
荣府这边也只有假证意志。后来十年曾山,与荣府增加了一个大房假设,又增加了一个宁国府。
这是导致红楼文本现象里,荣府二房文字细密,大房假设宁福假真两边,文字矛盾处颇多的主要原因。
为了把这个问题讲透彻,布红军将列举红楼梦中,关于宁国府的各个疑问,以未诸军解惑之意。
我们先来对比宁国府荣国府的绝尾差异。
就踪足地位而言,宁福为长,这是当年宁荣两宫的兄弟备份已留下来的旧例。
故而宁福假真担任俗长。
这也就解释了原住第五之三回,宁国府出席寄宗词。
假真这个组长准备了一些年货,发给没有生存伙计的假家人,这是他这位组长的责任。
就实际绝为而言,荣府则是高于宁福的。
对于这个信息,草血仅隐藏的很深,我们需要慢慢解破。
诸军情看第十三回,仅可亲死风龙境位。
假真觉得假荣的关街太低,于是花一千二百两赢子,
从大明宫长宫内向带权手中,买了一个龙境位的馅儿。
原住借此机会,对宁福降等习绝的现状进行了详细介绍。
假真看了盲宋语带权,看时上面写到,江南江宁福江宁显坚生假荣,年二十岁。
曾组圆认经营解读史世席一等神威将军假代化。
组以某颗境事假境,副世席三品绝威脸将军假真。
这就透露出红楼梦里的绝威成习,基本采用的是清带降等习绝的规则,
这业符合草血情的生存年代背景。
宁福第一代假演被称为宁国公,第二代假代化,便习的是一等神威将军的绝威。
再次假境假真,到了假真这里,已经将成了三品绝威脸将军。
按利来说,宁荣两宫当年同时习绝,那么顺着子孙降等习绝的方向,
宁荣两府的绝威成习现状应该是一样的,可是实实并不是这样。
第三回,林代玉泼附近京都,假予村为摸清时情,像林如海打听荣府内部情况,
林如海是这样打附的,如海笑道,若论社亲于尊兄游戏同普,乃荣公之孙,
大内兄现习一等将军,名设自恩后,而内兄名正自存州,现任公布原外狼,
其为人千公后道,大由祖父一风,非高良清博士换之流。
荣国府这边长子假设习绝,习的是一等将军。
对标的是宁国府的假代化,这就出现问题了,假设的备份比假代化低了一倍,
为什么习的绝威却是一样的。
按理来说,荣府之祖为荣国公假元,第二代假代善将等习绝应该成了一等将军,
到了假设这一代还要继续将等,为什么假设的绝威没有将,还是习了一等将军的绝威。
对于这个问题,红楼梦里其实给了答案。
第二是久违,轻虚惯达教,张道士负责接待假母一行人。
这个张道士是假代善当年在妙理的体身,封建时代有出家消灾解难之说,
假代善不可能自己出家,就让张道士当自己的体身。
在轻虚惯达教过程中,张道士和假母先了解当年的话题,说出来的话,破内寻位。
张道士又探道,我看见哥儿的这个形容深断严谈举动,怎么就同当日国公也一个狗子,
说着两眼留下累来,假母听说,也有不得满脸累狠,说到正式了。
我扬这些儿子孙子,也没一个像他爷爷的,就指着玉儿像他爷爷。
那张道士又像假真道,当日国公爷的母爷儿,爷们儿一辈的不用说,自然没赶上,
大约连大老爷二老爷也记不清楚了。
诸君注意细节,张道士这里提到的国公爷,显然指的就是假代善。
否则假母不会一听几哭,因为想起了死去的丈夫。
这就奇怪了,容国公明明是第一代假元,到了假代善这一代就应该降等,
为什么假代善却还被称为国公爷。
只要略微深入思考就不难推断,应该是假代善在尾期间曾立过大功,
再次被朝廷分为容国公。
到了他儿子假是这一代,就降等成了一等将军,和宁福的假代话反而成了评计。
用这条线索,也能解释通第二回,冷子星也说容国府。
提到假证的试图,冷子星说,次子假证自由库喜读书祖父罪疼,
原欲以刻假出身的。
不料带善临终时一本一上。
皇上因许先诚,即使令长子习惯外,问还有极子,立刻引见。
所以额外刺的这正老爹,一个主事之闲。
假代善临终一本,竟有这么大的作用。
可见他确实是容国公的等级。
皇帝也要体续这位工程,给他后代一些特殊待遇。
这种情况在临国府就没有出现。
在这个基础上,我们就不难探讨第二个问题,
即临国府的实际地位出现一遍的问题。
上面我们已经分析过,从绝位成习的角度来看,
容府的地位比临府要高。
各反应到具体情节上,情况就完全反了过来。
第13回,秦可亲死风龙进位。
这位临府孙习的桑里,办得过于龙中了。
这里的龙中,绝不是指桑里的奢华,
而是指其他贵族对这场桑里表现出来的反应。
坐着曹雪秦、杨洋洒洒,将这些贵族一一落裂。
从封建等级制度来看,这段描写无疑划张太过了。
正如杜春更之作,容宁两府两本书中的分析。
可亲桑市的夸张性是显然的。
像明中期以来的小说的文风,
而桑市规格过高,只不合理性,在书中是有内政可寻的。
他的功业也夹进死时,皇上依念骑士工程之后,才破历下旨。
朝中自王宫以下,准其记调亲死。
而可亲仅是夹进孙子的妻子,
不说其龙众和场面之大,
尽四王六宫,社彭陆记,就大不合理数了。
何况北境王还亲自出场去记?
如果要和理数,则宁府的地位应高于北境王,至少得不相上下才可。
秦可亲桑里的问题,立来研究者胜多,
流行五甚至提出了所谓的情绪。
认为秦可亲是废太子的女儿,
这种研究就完全脱离了红楼文本,已经不是研究红楼梦了。
而且,若是用这种影射之说,当成证论,
但红楼无人不可用此思路来解析,
那一步红楼真不知要被解读成何等无样了。
对于绝大多数堵者而言,这种解读是空虚的,反味的,难寻意义的。
其实何止秦可亲?
宁府这边有许多相似的情况,比如假境。
这位辞调官职一意选修的道实,却拥有莫名其妙的能量。
第十一回,静受臣宁府排家宴。
假境生日期间,收到了来自四大俊王送来的礼物。
假荣境来向有史说道,方才南安俊王、东平俊王、西宁俊王,
北京俊王四家王爷。
并正国公牛府等六家。
中进侯时府等八家,都拆人迟了明铁儿送兽礼来。
据回了我父亲,先收在账房里了,理单都上上党子了。
假境过一个生日,自己都没有回家。
居然隐得京都四王来送明铁兽礼。
而且假荣亲苗蛋写的说,据回了我父亲,先收在账房里。
假症一个小小的三品绝威脸将军,对四王似乎并不是很重视。
这跟荣府这边截然不同。
第十六回,假症也是过生日。
原住只是写道,宁荣二住人丁都奇极庆客热闹非常。
并未提及其他俊王公府,前来送礼祝贺。
生日艳上下泰舰前来,尽把荣国府上下,下得忙止住艳习,起中门贵街。
而宁国府假症,却和大明宫内向带权打得火热。
风龙尽未一回,带权甚至轻热地撑假荣为,咱们自家的孩子。
包括第33回,中顺王府长史官前来荣府,向家宝与所要细子齐官的线索。
假症听闻,赶紧令人快请,接着习忙走出来接待,对长史官更是陪孝起身来对话。
如果说假症的反应,才属于正常,
那么宁国府这边的许多人,许多是,都出现了和亲可亲桑里一样的夸张化描述。
这可不是一句,秦可亲是废太子之女,就能门混过关的。
通过对比不难发现,宁国府和荣国府的身份等级对照,出现了断裂的情况。
这种断裂还体现在,宁荣良府的婚家现象。
红楼梦中有,夹使王学四打家族。
第四回,胡录森乱盘胡录案。
门子就告诉家语村说,这四家街连路有亲,一损接损一容接容。
扶持遮饰具有照应。
可从具体经济来看,所谓的四家连路有亲,似乎只局限在荣国府。
宁国府完全不尊重这个规则。
荣国府这边,假带善取了精灵史家的小姐及石老太君。
假证取了精灵王家的小姐及王府人。
家连也取了精灵王家的王西奉。
这些婚姻,确实验证了四打家族连路有亲的说法。
当然,荣府这边也有例外,假诸取了国子间计酒离手中之女离完。
假名嫁给了叛花、灵如海。
但这些婚姻均可以定平为,假家要走科举阵新之路,
意有情理存烟不足为怪。
可到了宁国府这边,一切就都乱了。
假带话,假进的婚姻状况,草血情根本没体。
假证取了游氏,假容取了情可亲,后悠续嫌所谓的许世。
游氏的家族并不是有钱有事的大族。
这从他自家,游老娘,游二姐,三人的生存状况就能明显看出来。
游氏子妹,甚至需要出卖身子,才能谋得生存空间。
游老娘更是小家的出身,见到一点赢头小利,
就能把女儿的终身给牺牲掉。
当然,按照红楼的设置,游老娘是改嫁。
但即便把这个情况考虑进去,
我们也很难想象,游家会是什么明文旺族。
琴可亲面临同样的问题。
按照原住的技术,她是营善狼,情业之女,
而且不是亲生女儿,是情业当年从养生堂抱回来的。
尽管如此,琴可亲照样嫁给宁府迪子假容,
成了正儿八景的龙大奶奶。
不读连因这一条,纳切意识如此。
婚姻的规则在龙国府这边是十分明狼的,
那就是一期两切制。
比如假证的正期是王府人,另有两个世界,
分别为赵一娘,周一娘。
这种规则也会落到假保育头上。
陈大康在龙国府的经济帐里,对于龙府纳切的具体考量
就有如下分析。
佳谋为保育选重的席人是,
性情合顺,举止沉重。
齐文泽千零百例,嘴间姓大。
这是柔刚相应的组合。
周一娘在书中从不发生,
不卷入矛盾,当时温顺之人。
她与机密精明的赵一娘,
也是柔刚相应的组合。
而剧第七十八回里的介绍,
假证起初天性也是个十九放弹之人,
并非现在书中所看到的鱼府东宫,
专恨玩故的形象。
这三人的搭配形成一种平衡。
可这种一期两切的规则,
在宁府这边显然是不适用的。
假证的切是远远超标了。
第七回王夕奉甲保育做客宁国府。
早有假证之期优势,
与假容之期情势颇息两个。
引了多少机械压换媳妇等接触移门。
今次一处,
足以证明假证之机械重多,
远不是容服两切的标准。
当然,
论到此处,
必然独者会指出另一个人物来,
那就是假设。
假设是容国府的人,
可她取得妻子却是行服人。
而且假设比起假证,
更是有过之而无不及。
第三回领带预进假府,
跟随行服人去拜见假设。
意识进入正式,
早有许多盛装力服质机械压换赢者。
假设早有多个机械,
却还是将谋找生象了假母的贴身压缓冤养。
被家母拒绝后,
仍是不改色心,
花了八百两赢子,
买了一个十七岁的小姑娘烟红当切。
有此关职,
假设虽是容府中人,
其连阴纳切为人处事,
到向是宁国府那边的人。
为何会出现这种情况,
答案其实很简单。
欧罗孟最早写出来的时候,
只有容国府假证意识。
宁国府假证,
以及容国府假设,
都是后来天上去的。
具体的创作过程应该是,
石头记风月宝剑二书合并二来。
假设这个人物的增加,
有细心的独者恐怕早已察觉。
假设身为容府长死,
而且习了一等将军的绝位。
案例说,
容国府应该掌握在她的手上,
可实际上容府的核心权利
却在二房假设一边。
甚至象征接级地位的容喜堂
也归了二房。
大房反驻在容府隔断花园一侧,
两房各门各户,
进出都要坐车,分明是两家人。
房间一论此情节,
困于红楼梦既定的人物设置,
只能四处猜测。
以为家母天爱二房,
将容府从大房手中奪走。
说不知,
红楼早本并无假设,
假证一知乃是主角。
后期加入假设,
若让她抢走容府地位,
则前番文字全部摩倒,
成了废文。
故而只能动用上帝视角,
将假设罗旨隔断花园一侧。
红楼梦中关于宁国府的文字,
应都是出子风月宝剑。
包括假瑞,多姑娘,
游氏子妹等人物的相关文字。
风月宝剑涉及风月之情,
文笔漏谷,
迫有精平之风。
比如假瑞在镜子里优惠奉剑,
翻云负语中经济而亡。
在如假脸多姑娘优惠,
迎太摆出,
全然不顾其夫多魂崇正在一旁寒水。
至于石头记经临十二拆得点雅隔掉,
显然不符,
应是二书结合而成,
对于这个观点,
前人多有论数。
庇如第二回,
假语村冷子心论容国府,
两人对话如下。
自心道,
容国府中假府中,
可也殿入了先生的门没吗?
语村笑斗,
原来是他家,
若论起来,
寒足人丁却不少,
自东汉家父以来,
知派凡胜,
各省皆有,
谁主席讨查得来。
若论容国一知,
却是同普,
但他那等容要,
我们不便去攀扯。
至今故月发生书难认了。
自心探道,
老先生羞辱此说,
如今的这容国两门也都消书了,
不比现实的光记。
语村道,
当日宁容两宅的人口也极多,
如何就消书了。
马万里赵耀章先生
分析原住此段,
频道是,
这段对话农缩的展现了增山过程,
作者先输容国一知,
后便宁容两宅,
中间革着容国两门,
这容国两门落到时尚,
只能试职假设假证,
一扔演说容国一府,
但作者留有深意,
一容字上成容国一知,
平两字引进宁容两宅,
就借容国两门这个过门,
仅仅二十五个字塞进一个宁国府,
归府神功比例超绝,
不过,白纸黑字,
宁国府的来路在这儿
也留下了千古确证,
证明宁国府是后纳入容国府的,
证明红楼梦的早期书稿,
原本只有一个容国府,
只有容国一知,
而不是宁容两宅,
张爱琳在红楼梦眼之,
就是真本一节中,
也同样认为,
第一个早本中没有宁府和假设,
也没有假语村,
甚至没有真假,
宁容两府在联赢原则,
极竊选择上出现反差,
便是因为原本二者是独立的个体,
两书和为艺书,
细节处要进行模合,
但到底没办法严私何逢,
类似的情况还有假西春,
曹雪琴将她设置为假禁之女,
假真宝妹,
可纵观红楼全书,
西春跟宁府基本没有交集,
甚至琴可亲去世,
假禁去世,
这些必不可缺的场合,
西春也没有出现,
在由假真的年龄,
第54回王夕鳳孝细彩班姨,
鳳姐提到假真,
其言语说的是,
外头的只有一位真大爷,
我们还是论哥哥妹妹,
从小一处逃起了这么大,
可假真的年龄要比王夕鳳大多,
他们不可能从小一处逃起,
假真的儿子假荣都已经取棋,
只比王夕鳳小几岁,
王夕鳳不可能跟假真从小一起长大,
这也是一处漏洞,
还有下人称呼上的重合,
比如,假脸和暴尔家的私混,
后暴尔家的上调自己,
此处暴尔夫妇显然是荣国府的人,
可到了第64回,
暴尔夫妇不如花之相,
服侍幼儿姐,
已经成了假真的手下,
这些种种都足以说明,
红楼梦的成书过程极其复杂,
草血秦十年山改增山五次,
并不是对原稿进行修改,
更多的是将风月宝剑移入石头记之后,
二者故事需要进行荣何,
这种荣何带来无修指的增山与潤色,
它成就了红楼梦的文学志尊地位,
也带来了说知不尽的红楼研究,
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,
我们下个视频再会。